computer how do I put the jail
quickest route no freeways computer do
you hear me I've just taken away your
computer privileges yes sir it's time
for you to stop this unhealthy behavior
you can't spend the rest of your life
alone dressed in black and staying up
all night
it's morning you need to take
responsibility for your life and it
starts by raising your son I'm sorry I
literally have no idea what you're
talking about
the young orphan you adopted at the
garner I thought I was being sarcastic
your time right whoa wait just Batman
live in Bruce Wayne's basement no Bruce
Wayne lives in Batman's attic don't
touch that the Morea what is culturally
insensitive a terror what are we
thinking this glam bat this will
absolutely none wait what's that one
there I love it my only trouble is these
pants are just a little tight I got an
idea it's better now I'm free now I'm
moving come on Batman let's get grooving
I can only look you in the eyes right
now are you ready to follow Batman and
maybe learn a few life lessons along the
way you're in but first where's the seat
belt the first lesson is life doesn't
give you seat belts
anything I do it
Oh Alfred I have incredible reflexes
Oh oh my goodness I am so sorry as soon
as I get back to the Batcave I will make
sure that Alfred puts seat belts on
there but for the time being I'm just
gonna put my arm right here and we're
just gonna gently ease out of here you
know gentle like what is the password
nananananananana Batman thank you I love
it